you weapons about weap okay just relax I
don't
have sure there's nothing that's going
to hurt us so that we can talk okay okay
all
right okay I'm going to go check
all right ma'am turn around talk to so
what's going on today nothing I was
irritated what were you irritated about
clear they her being NY yesterday they
did what cuz I was being NY yesterday
okay what what did they do about that
brought me up forth brot you up
yes no no okay
um so what's the reason that you think
the police have been called here today I
don't
know because I haven't done anything I I
just said it for frustration cuz I'm
irritated what did you say to him that I
didn't say anything to
anybody okay so that they're saying that
you threaten I was no I wasn't threaten
for for that at all what did you say
that maybe they misunderstood about cuz
they don't understand me one bit
cuz I thought I was
uh CU I always I always sick today and
they wouldn't let me go home at
home okay hard to be work
you open all right um
negative were you supposed to work today
I was working last night yes okay you
work like the graveyard sh be there just
so um what time were you supposed to get
off 7 7 time is it 7:50 okay what made
you decide to to stay in your car I was
smoking a cigarette cuz I don't smoke
and
drive okay and I don't uh drive while
I'm irritated it's probably best you
don't want to drive angry right right
okay
um do you have an idea anything like
that all
right talk to her for a minute while
M all
right so you're kind of telling her disr
didn't say anything we sure we didn't
say anything to anyone about how pissed
off you were nothing like that I was yes
I was pissed off but I wasn't saying
that I was saying out of frustration
saying what about what the gun and
everything what did you say about the
gun popping off but I was trying to how
I
feel without me doing with the Y with
the threat you
so how I want to put
this
with me by yelling that's I so I want go
uh post on but okay fine with me being
frustrated so if I understand correctly
you're saying if you you believe that if
you vent out your frustration it'll keep
you from actually doing the action
right how long have you worked here
since June of this year
it was like the 8th of July started okay
have you been in trouble before with to
police or any other police department
anything like that no speed how was
about it I have no war for an arrest
okay stay
there just stay over
there if you want to talk to her real
quick
there was a 22 on the car okay we' got
all the so I don't know I need to stay
with her
until so what do you do here overnight
ster that's a rough job yes you work 5
days a week
yes overnight stuff's hard yes very much
so and I'm going to do the Lost
dress okay that's
understandable
did you
[Music]
get highspeed chases we got up unruly
suspects I will kill that mother me no
do it stay in the bo I like dramatic DUI
I'mma pass everything that she trying to
do and shocking body cam footage hey get
on the ground get on the ground law on
crime presents body cam the place for
real raw and wild police videos you
should have seen it it was good it's on
body camera I'll show it to you catch
the action and subscribe to our new
YouTube channel
now get we'll go uh we'll go back in the
store okay to your security office we
already in charge her since she had G
we're going take her to jail okay so
I'll need a witness statement from you
who all heard what these are the two
that heard people that were there when
she said it okay I'll get W statements
from can they be in your office for long
enough to do that okay let's all go back
inside and I'll get those can I go tell
my roomate what's happening yeah of
course of course yes in
[Applause]
the I have no drugs on part all I I have
is that clock for safety that's about it
okay just the one just that one okay and
yes it was loaded just for that reason
for what re but safety CU I work night
and I come outside
understandable in the area that I work
in is this car really going to try to
back out next to you
yes
all
right are you serious yes
ma'am so I lost my job
dad can I at least hand my badge and my
discount card
relax I'm going to talk to my
supervisor
all right she's going to be searching
you so is there anything on who's going
to poke sticker nothing like that no my
box knife is in my car good no sharp
needles no I don't do that that stuff at
all I'm clean except for the cigarettes
I figured but I ask everybody cuz you
never know some people find steps to put
in their pocket for thr away yeah like I
said I don't
okay
Che all
right have such of evental therapy to
talk about okay guys how are you
doing better you know she just doesn't
look like the person who would walk in
and say I'm going to kill everybody
he she's just a very angry person angry
person yeah she was the loudest in the
story I would say all right so what I
want on these is um leave this blank for
now we're probably going to make that
Walmart okay uh write print your
name your
address leave this one blank so if I put
an X in leave blank yeah and then uh
your best home phone number write your
statement of what she
said sign it
here and then make sure down here you
put your name your address
your phone
number your date of birth excuse me and
a so short license number one of the two
all
right there you
go do you need this spot over here oh no
okay and my keys I yeah we'll get your
keys you're oh they're in the car yeah
I got my
[Applause]
car
yes mhm
that be from there in though since it's
is Poli but it's also has not it's
always been in a private
lock so that's when they're going to
have to
call okay do a better SE wasn't part of
the
CR
no I good
question
all
right do you have any weapons anywhere
else no I
[Music]
don't okay can I be walk somewhere else
I have anxiety like really B and then I
have the box for the pistol as well grab
that too um SC has
either standing with PS on or sitting in
my car for while PS on and which is very
no I mean around the car
please I don't want to pop up on the
Army but you don't want to
look hang out
right
okay huh what you want I need to get
information for the report and put her
in a
car she go in my
car going that white exp right
there got front passenger
side hello hello how's it
going another exciting day at Walmart
always never do
moment yeah
hey are you still confused on that like
no I was been frustrated I can't say why
I need to say that they off
frustration well when cops well listen
listen you can to an extent but when you
when you threaten listen listen it
doesn't matter it's the same as if
somebody goes in and like threatens a
school or something cuz I wasn't
actually going to do it especially when
you have the ability to carry out the
axe when you actually have a gun in your
car was got to really do it okay doesn't
matter we don't we can't operate that
way we can't operate that way cuz if we
leave you here and then you go in CUV I
was do it doesn't matter you're an adult
I was got leave you no it doesn't matter
you're an adult the words you say matter
words matter and when you threaten and
when you threaten someone it is not an
empty statement that just kind of goes
thetive statement well that's you the
rest of the world does not work that way
so have a seat down it's kind of hard
for me to sit
[Applause]
down you go on the other side I
will yeah I don't think they were going
to hire you back anyway hun you threaten
your boss and other threatening me the
words you used and the structure you use
them is called the threat thanks
sir
no those are
hers I'm too worried about her jump in
the center now what did she say to you
Kennedy um like when like all together
EXA what happened well she came walking
up saying how she was all angry and to
drive and everything too angry to drive
yeah she was sitting her car first while
we were sitting at the area and she was
saying what she always says she always
has a problem with maner CHR coming on
to her because she yells at he coaches
for usually I'm just like
yeah
but every day she yells every day she
get in trouble for it and it's
just and I was like girl you got you got
to deal with your problems way you got
to find something else like therapy we
all of us have anger issues all of us
have issues you have to find another way
to deal with it than yelling at your
boss you just can't and that's when she
just said that she like she either yell
at people or she would shoot
them and did she's the one to tell you
she had two gun who did she tell she had
two guns in um I previous got a ride
from her so I knew she had a gun in her
glove box I believe
okay and she gave me ride several times
so i' seen it at least five times okay
put that in your report he told me that
after when she walked away and that's
when I was like I need to go tell Chris
about this okay
okay and she how did she word it again
I'm going to what how did she I have to
yell at him or I would shoot him
okay okay good even have Apartments yes
they do it's a it's it's a house it's
like one one no there's more than one
it's been it's been a while since I've
been to
K she got it on too tight it's a lot of
times it's just the wa the angle of the
seat there there's not a lot you can do
at the SE I meant the add cuffs that's
what I mean cuz it's like jabbing me up
there in the um my blood vessel
yeah okay do you have any health issues
uh anxiety okay do you take any
medication for that no have you ever
been seen for your anxiety no I just got
diagnosed in March after got much my leg
you got diagnosed for anxiety in March
yes I'm going to run in and make sure I
get correct information enough for an AB
and I totally would have done that I for
for some reason thought Edge had a
rookie the way he was acting I was like
okay he's taking this cuz he has a
rookie and then he left and I was like
what so yeah he's inside I'm getting all
her information so you do whatever you
need okay just so I don't forget them
set them down somewhere those are her
keys I'm going to run in and then I'll
be who has the gun huh who has the gun
uh Z and Greg are taking it to turn it
in okay so Ed is gonna do the do I get
that if I get out getting all the story
nice yeah cool yeah do I get that back
when I get
out yes um but it's not going to be an
immediate okay it's going to be a little
while it's it's going to be a little
while so I guess has never been shot
except for uh did you buy it new targets
did you buy it new it was my sister's
okay yeah so she sold it to me directly
yeah so all I have paperwork for it
that's fine so you live in Oklahoma we
we're good with that so the biggest
thing you'll need to understand is when
you go to pick up the firearm you will
want to call the property room
beforehand you can look online and get
that number um because uh it's state law
that anytime a firearm is turned in
whether it's evidence or not this case
it is evidence um it will need to be
test fired okay want to make sure it has
been cleaned in a little while it's fine
uh it though they'll test fire it make
sure everything's good make sure it's a
safe gun and then they're going to do a
background check on you to make sure
that you're going to be able to have the
gun same as you would if you would have
gone to a gun store like I said it's and
listen let me finish I'm almost done and
then after that it depends whether or
not the people here at Walmart or
whoever it was that's the victim in this
wants to press charges if they want to
press charges on you for threatening a
violent act it will be the gun will be
held until after all the court stuff is
done okay
okay like I said people don't understand
me once to in bit I just did out
frustration yeah ma'am you can't do
that express myself well you need to
find another way to express yourself a
problem I can't then you might need to
go talk to somebody because the people
that Express stuff like that have
extreme usually anger issues that's what
I have well and listen and those people
as you put it pop off and do stuff like
shoot people in a parking lot yeah I'm
That Kind of well but listen but listen
the jump it takes between getting upset
and verbally saying I'm going to do
damage with this firearm and actually
doing that firearm is much closer than
people who don't say anything and just
leave or just yell nonsense and then
leave when you make a very tangible
threat and then you have the capability
of doing that because you do have a gun
right I wasn't going to like do it
though but who nobody can know that for
sure except you right right so everyone
else that is
involved believes you can right my
mother but I'm not going to really do it
but your mother's not here your mother's
not the one you're talking to so I would
highly
recommend when all this is said and done
if this is an ongoing issue how old are
you right now 36 you're 36 yeah it's not
ongoing for me so listen if you're 36
and having difficulty with this you need
to go talk to a therapist or
psychiatrist to figure out another
method of releasing this anger and
there's nothing wrong with going to talk
to somebody about anger issues a lot of
people should be doing that but you need
to do it because it got you today in a
whole bunch of trouble well oh a lot of
people do it without anger yeah but a
lot of people don't have the gun I know
but I wasn't going to do go really do do
though but do you do you understand
where we're at yes okay
so that's why we're under arrest today
that's why we have to take your gun
that's why all this day has been turned
over if you just wouldn't have said
anything and just
left you'd be home you'd be home and
upset but you wouldn't be stuck in my
car you wouldn't be stuck in
handcuffs
okay there comes a time when you have to
learn to deal with your anger and
channel it and channel it in a way
that's not destructive you verbally
being destructive
is what gots you in
trouble now for instance if we would
have come here and you didn't have a
gun it still would have been a report it
still would have been a threat but you
couldn't have actually done anything cuz
you didn't have a gun right
right but that's not where we're at
today
so
[Applause]
and it's a 22 pistol yes it's a clock
okay they just came out with those I
don't know when she bought it but she
did cuz she get a a discount a discount
on it military very nice
Air Force my whole family's Air Force
except for my
uncle are they got to to my car or they
got to keep it there until I get out
that is up to Walmart that'll be up to
Henry where where did you work at before
Walmart Walmart oh it's another Walmart
yeah I worked in S springs K Jinx Broken
Arrow so what was the reason for today's
argument that caused all of this to go
down like I was irritated cuz the uh
FedEx was uh laid on my
medicine what medicine if you don't mind
me asking my uh for my arm for my elbow
cuz I have
uh uh like for arthritis or uh psoriasis
psoriasis I won't be getting that at all
CU now I can't afford
it so you were upset cuz FedEx didn't
deliver my medicine your medicine
correct okay where do they deliver here
or at home they delivered up to my house
okay so you didn't get it so I'm I'm
sure if it's psoriasis on your arm it's
irritating and it hurts right yeah sis
is no joke so you're in pain you're in
there what caused you to lash out at
your at Henry is that the guy no I was
my uh at he's my Academy trainer okay so
were you upset with the academy trainer
no I was just irritated cuz I didn't
deliver it until like yesterday okay so
who did you say did you just spurt out
like that you were going to pop off with
your no I was sick and he wouldn't let
me go home oh he wouldn't let you go
home yes what time do you usually get
off seven but I was lightheaded I was
nauseous because I made myself
sick my hands are going
numb they'll go DB just a little bit
just because of the sitting in the seat
with the cuffs on but it'll be okay once
we get once we get to where we're going
we'll take them
off that's like my whole hands on both
sides
yeah sadly there's no real comfortable
way no there's
not
[Applause]
how tall are
you 57 I believe because I think I Shon
[Applause]
still approximately how much do you
weigh uh
319 that was 317 or 377 good for
you one is you join the Air Force that
the rest of your family went uh if you
don't I'm
handicapped how are you handicapped I
got a learning disability um did they
actually tell you what it is like or is
it just that you have learning
disability I have a learning disability
okay my parents found out I learn slower
than everybody
else did you finish High School yes
fresh I got the the TOA at the house
good for
you I hope that won hire me down after
this Maybe not maybe just a different
Walmart then they just not might be fine
I'm going to put your phones right here
well that that one phone going back to
Walmart oh you have a work phone yes H I
know Walmart T work phones yeah that's
like the um handhelds that we used to
use yeah they decided to go with a phone
instead yes cuz it was cheaper that way
gotcha my whole family work for one more
two
keep it in the family right maybe
not
right I got your keys and your phone be
around on that side in just a second
we'll get you out of here okay get those
CS off do you have any piercings or
anything no I don't okay just your
necklace yeah with my R yes y one I'm
about to sell
anyways all right Miss
Edwards
can barely feel my fingers yeah we'll
get that fixed here in just second make
sure you didn't drop anything out your
pocket
nope I wish I made handcuff can feel
your fingers
yeah you have to come up with anything
like
that no there's just really not any way
to restrain hands in it not be
uncomfortable that's really
secure ouch
yep all
right go to the seat right there
for that that's the hand that was Hur
the worst
all right we'll need your watch and
jewelry I'm assuming you need the
glasses to see hey can't see without
them all right so you can keep
those want my wallet too yes please
wallet CH well the chain go with my
wallet um I'll get
the uh her P ID number and the car
information off the computer you already
got it um I have the
car don't have her p number on I'll go
grab that real quick
okay this is a thing now push button and
intake window exit that's new that
wasn't oh here's my my earbuds and my
wallet I forgot that was in my pocket
thank you
ma'am
but
I but say did you Happ to ask her if she
was of any travel affili no I have not
yet Adrian are you m of any of the
Civilized Tri is the button I'm supposed
to press to get out of here you guys
press it or I press
it where's it at so I don't have to ask
anymore this side or this side oh I see
it thank you it's on the actual desk
that's a strange to play
sport
e
big
sheet
has address on
your yes but it's in your system wrong
though I got down here
too
prob 214 Road 214
Road
be pass location not moving of breathing
8 what's your padge
2028 living in the future
huh
right see
welcome
for
all right Miss Edwards I got some
questions for you real quick yes sir are
you currently under any kind of
psychiatric or general Doctor's Care you
seen a doctor regularly for anything
nope are you taking any prescription
medications
uh you said your psoriasis medication
anything else uh that's about is the uh
my psorasis
medication are you wearing any
prosthetic brace or medical device no no
pacemakers fake legs no it's all real
it's all normal have you been seen or
treated in a Clinic hospital or
emergency room in the last 3 days
no do you feel suicidal or have you
thought about harming yourself
no are you pregnant nope
thank you
man you have a wonderful
day
what I I'm taking somebody
back you had to call the on this morning
for somebody excuse me officer can you P
that button over
there where is it other side of the
bottle other side of the bottle I got
you the BX hole B hole I was doing the
same thing
okay they should have made that piece of
paper red or yellow or yellow just
something to stick
out
is Edward what's your social security
number awesome thank
you 52
yes let's see we got a
watch two rings one
necklace
wallet two
phones going for work well was
works and
keys what is your batch number
2545 I
oh and the wall if you want to put that
down there's also 20 bucks not W yes
that will be taken out and put in
separately okay um just because it's
money that's they they put it the safe
and everything I appreciate
it
make I appreciate that you're welcome
that's a lot of paperwork right um which
one is your personal the blue one blue
one I'm and turn this one off and then
we'll get thr numbers out of the other
one it's
well yeah it looks like it needs a
code and if you want to get those phone
numbers here is a
pen and a card you can write the phone
numbers you need on the back of all
right you want to list next to Ken uh
like sister or mother is that what
you're talking about yeah which
one mother is going to be awfully
upset what's Mom's name
yon same last name
yes oh my goodness really what's your
mom's address same with
mine
what's your phone number about to get
get it out now that's what you're
getting on
[Applause]
yes
I'm right handed so this going to be
difficult get a
couple
yeah I promise I'm not going
[Applause]
nowhere
up
okay
okay when you are released from here you
need to be sure and pick up all of your
property because if it
stays past seven days they end up uh
throwing it away cuz they can't house
everybody's stuff
so just when you leave just go ahead and
grab it and take it with you
okay I don't understand why people
wouldn't do that in the first place but
it's something we got to make sure
people understand now
oh come on
get I hate these stupid
things
C
all
done with your phones I'm done with the
phones for now
put that in your pocket if you wouldn't
mind just Pat your pockets just make
sure you don't have any loose chain or
bobby pins something crazy like that in
there I don't okay do you have anything
in your
hair no okay it's kind of silly if my
hair
short never know these days
right and did you say that you have no
tribal affiliation no CU my grandmother
didn't cross the border to sign the
[Music]
paperwork with the black
wood
what was the address of that Walmart 311
thank
you if you would sign this for me right
here this is just stting that you have
no tribal affiliation therefore you will
not be shipped off to tribal
court
I hate my
handwriting
any
you show
me49
for
did you talk to her any that car a
little bit um she has a Lear disability
um
apparently she got upset because her
medication did not commit from FedEx to
her house her soris medication so she
said she was in pain and she wanted to
leave
and her boss said no so she get upset
she kept saying that the reason she was
any kind of a threat even though in her
eyes it's not a threat is because that's
how she learns to deal with her anger
management issues is to voice it rather
than
she did exactly what he
said they're not going bre oh true she's
not going to get me done because she's
my that's okay yeah Bigg thing today
she's upset and that's what what we
talked that's mostly what we talked
about it's like 36 I understand that
this is how you've dealt with it before
but in the real world people can't I
can't think what inside your head so and
she's like my mama understand I like but
you're not talking to your M you're
talking to people that don't know what
you're thinking you don't know what
you're capable of and today you were
capable because you did have a card or
she go I know I was like well this is
the thing you have to remember you are
an adult the words you say
matter um I got one I'm pretty sure but
it's up to
you are we just not sure it's her
Miss Edwards what's your middle name I'm
GNA explain your rights to
you I don't no this isn't her different
social security
number and you have a right to not
answer any questions if
that okay
with that being said
um I just want to make sure I understood
what happened
today you feel better
yelling and when you yell
today what did you
say thanks
sir
that yeah
about what
the
heist I
had my wife has it it's
it hurts it it does and it
itches
okay they said that you said that you
either yell or you're you would shoot
him I or so you don't shoot with me
forget my frustration out I said what I
said so I wouldn't shoot him okay but
you didn't mean exactly you didn't mean
took it the wrong way
okay I know my partner did discuss with
you about words and Society you know you
hear about employees going sh place all
the time right that I would never I know
better than that that's the reason why I
said
it I just wanted make sure I your side
of the
story question
the new
paint
thing they had last time didn't see that
one they like half black half like this
weird blue color M that was like they
had the image do it so the lines were
like was
disgusting all right Miss Edwards this
is all your property
okay when you go through you'll take
that with you okay um your money is in a
separate envelope it'll be put through
with the paper work and they will put
that in their little Vault okay so
depending on if you want to put on your
books you do you know what that means I
yeah kind of if you want if you want to
pay if you want to pay for stuff in here
whether it I would assuming be more
phone calls or snacks or whatever if
you're in here that long you probably
won't be but if you were you can have
that money put on that tab so you can
use that $20 if not they'll give it to
you when you leave just make sure you
make make sure you have all your
property the receipt is also there this
is this piece of paper you can go
through and make sure all your stuff is
there I cataloged everything okay
nothing will be stolen at nope you know
it'll all stay in that bag yeah but this
isn't prison this this is a this this is
a short-term stay I hope this will be
short term and thaty LW I don't think
you'll be here too
longing
charges
have you ever gone to uh family
children's for your anxiety no I would
highly recommend it okay um or if you've
gone to some other counselor or
therapist I have not been I would highly
recommend it um like I said there's
nothing wrong with talking to somebody
and figuring out other tools to use
besides just what you've been doing
verbalizing what you're thinking right
that's that's dangerous as we've learned
today right right um because heaven
forbid you would do that to somebody
that actually would wish you harm and
then they have the right to hurt you
because you have the right to hurt me
that I'll be defending
myself see what I'm
saying that's not correct but what what
you need to do is you need to have the
tools to be able to bring the anger
level down bring out the frustration in
a way that's not going to want to get
you in trouble and two that's healthy
because what you've been doing isn't
healthy that actually can make the anger
keep going and it just builds up and
builds up and then when it gets too much
my no sh but it's work that's that's
what I'm saying that's what therapist
and psychiatrists are there for is to
help figure out okay where is it coming
from because anger is a secondary
response all right there's usually
something else going on that causes you
to be angry right you're not just all of
a sudden angry so they dig into that and
go okay when this happens and you feel
this way do this instead okay okay so I
would highly recommend doing that okay